Prince Harry and Megan Markel are
visiting Northern Ireland today there
they are as part of their first official
joint visit to the province the couple's
wedding is just eight weeks away now may
19th yesterday Kensington Palace
announced the official wedding
invitations are in the mail Charlie
d'Agata is in London outside Kensington
Palace charlie good morning to you good
morning 56 days but who's counting well
we're counting obviously for those who
have been invited just receiving that
golden ticket will be an event in itself
behold the most coveted wedding
invitation of the century not counting
that other one the gilded invites are
printed in American ink on English paper
in keeping with the transatlantic spirit
of their union handmade by the
delightfully named apprentice Lottie
small the West thing is keeping it from
women not being able to saw my mum
because anything else she'd be the first
person but secrets remain who may be on
that list and not royal correspondent
boy Anika do you think President Trump
or any of the families gonna be invited
no president Trump won't be invited and
he was never expected to be invited this
is not a state occasion it's not a state
wedding the invitation also reveals a
traditional dress code uniform morning
coat or lounge suit day dress with hat
whether Harry now general captain of the
Royal Marines will dawn full military
dress as he did for his brother's
wedding or opts for a slightly dressed
down morning suit is anybody's guess
there's an even more exclusive list only
200 guests made the cut for the private
reception that night at Frogmore house
Frogmore house the evening 200 people
very close family and friends they're
doing that so that everyone gets to see
the pair of them
and also that it stays very private and
probably isn't especially on social
media everywhere it served as a kind of
hideout when the couple's romance was on
the down-low and became the location of
their first official engagement shoot so
the guest list is multi-tiered kind of
like a wedding cake you've got the 200
that are at the reception that night 600
that in the church service
another 2,600 members of the public have
been invited to Windsor Castle to
witness the arrival of the the couple
the carriage and that wedding gown up
close John Charlie d'Agata at Kensington
Palace thanks charlie well go well you
know I want to go and I also know I'm
not getting an invitation so it's just
wishful thinking but I'm very fascinated
by both of them and I think they make
such a great couple
I'm sure how many people are gonna get
an invitation for whom it's it's going
to be an actual surprise an exclusive
party and then an even more exclusive
party right very nice